Marlo go we'll soon closed for the
season so the president spending time
this weekend at what could become his
summer White House trump National Golf
Club in Bedminster New Jersey Don Dahler
is there with the town's reaction Don
good morning good morning Bedminster is
an affluent community where about a
quarter of the households earn more than
$200,000 but the infrastructure here
really isn't set up for large crowds nor
all the media that will descend on this
area the the President's Club is about a
mile down this two-lane road where signs
have popped up saying no stopping no
standing and many around here are
wondering who's going to foot the bill
for the extra security costs the
president arrived last night to a
familiar destination he's had Trump
Bedminster for as long as I can remember
and he's been here so many weekends
trump National Golf Club sits on a
36-hole course with a pool dining area
and several cottages and Suites
membership can reportedly cost about
$300,000 it's where President Trump's
daughter Ivanka married Jared Kushner in
2009 and where mr. Trump once said he
wanted to be buried
he spent three days here as
president-elect interviewing potential
cabinet members we have a lot of horses
yeah
Mayor Stephen Parker says a town can
handle the spotlight I think it's going
to be a big non-event here so a big
non-event the president coming to town
it's flattering that the president
enjoys Bedminster like our residents do
but but I don't think it's going to be
terribly disruptive but it could be
pricey for a government with just 16
police officers added security around
mar-a-lago during president Trump's
visits has reportedly cost surrounding
governments more than three and a half
million dollars the mayor of Bedminster
predicts his Township alone could have
to pay 300 thousand dollars to support
the president's travel this summer do
you have it in the budget we do not have
a separate line item set aside that
specifically takes care of that so we're
all working together to try to find that
source some of the people who live here
would rather not have to deal with it
mr. president you're welcome to come but
please don't
so here's yon worries heavy security
could make it difficult to get around
from the common citizens point of view
it'll be a nightmare complete nightmare
but antique shop owner and Brooks isn't
complaining I know there will be flight
road closures just on arrival and
departure but other than that we are
hoping for more traffic I guess for
business like yours along the main
thoroughfare and this in this area more
traffic is a good thing always a good
thing
the mayor is asking for federal funds to
help defray the cost of the presidential
visits by the way there are flight
restrictions in this area there's a 10
mile no-fly zone that's going to impact
flights in and out of Newark and it's
probably going to ground the smaller
planes from leaving the smaller airports
in this area Gayle Don thank you